A couple years ago,
I was in college pursuing meteorology.
That was considered great.
A couple years ago,
I was into the bodybuilding industry,
and I was into fitness modeling.
That was awesome.
However, when I decide I want to drop out of college
and become a traditional wife,
and my only goal in life
is to be an amazing wife and mother,
that's when eyebrows seem to raise.
When I was younger,
I grew up in a traditional Indian community,
and a lot of these families were from India,
and they moved into this community
to live with each other.
And there were both housewives
and career women in these families.
And they always said how accepted and appreciated
both housewives and career women are in India.
I've also nanny for quite a few Indian families,
and they've all said the same thing.
So what is it about the west
that wants to devalue traditional wives?